if you get married they think you're
finished
and if you are without a woman they
think you are incomplete
if you have the ability to love
love yourself first
do you hate people
i don't hate them
i just feel better when they're not
around
the nine to five is one of the greatest
atrocities sprung upon mankind
you give your life away to a function
that doesn't interest you
your ambition
is handicapped by laziness
we are here to laugh at the odds
and live our lives so well
that death will tremble to take us
genius might be the ability to say a
profound thing in a simple way
there are only two things wrong with
money
too much
or too little
we don't even ask happiness
just a little less pain
love is all right for those who can
handle the psychic overload
it's like trying to carry a full garbage
can on your back over a rushing river of
piss
almost everybody is born a genius
and buried an idiot
people are strange
they are constantly angered by trivial
things
but on a major matter like totally
wasting their lives
they hardly seem to notice
[Music]
of course it's possible to love a human
being
if you don't know them too well
real loneliness
is not necessarily limited to when you
are alone
there is always one woman to save you
from another
and as that woman saves you she makes
ready to destroy
nothing is worse than to finish a good
[ __ ]
then reach over and find the toilet
paper container empty even the most
horrible human being on earth deserves
to wipe his ass
bad taste creates many more millionaires
than good taste
sometimes you climb out of bed in the
morning and you think
i'm not going to make it
but you laugh inside
remembering all the times you've felt
that way
people run from rain
but sit in bathtubs full of water
i guess the only time most people think
about injustice
is when it happens to them
dogs and angels
are not very far apart
love is like a serious illness
an illness from which you never entirely
recover
find what you love
and let it kill you
what matters most is how well you walk
through the fire
there is loneliness in this world so
great
that you can see it in the slow movement
of a clock's hand
if you're going to try
go all the way
otherwise don't even start
i have always liked visiting women
myself
more than
when they are visiting me
you can always get away from them
the shortest distance between two points
is often unbearable
we must bring our own light
to the darkness
you are not promised anything in life
no contract was signed with you
the less i needed
the better i felt
there are worse things than being alone
but it often takes decades to realize
this and most often when you do
it's too late
and there's nothing worse than too late
ambition rarely helps talent
another thing is luck
talent always trails behind her
if you're losing your soul and you know
it
then you've still got a soul left to
lose
[Music]
the difference between a democracy and a
dictatorship
is that in a democracy you vote first
and take orders
later in a dictatorship
you don't have to waste your time voting
[Music]
some people never go crazy
what truly horrible lives they must lead
as humans
we adjust to new conditions and
discoveries
we are pliable
there are times when those eyes inside
your brain stare back at you
how can you trust a creature that bleeds
every month and doesn't lie
of course it's
possible to love a human being
if you don't know them too well
you begin saving the world by saving one
man at a time
all else is grandiose romanticism or
politics
some moments are nice
some are nicer
some are even worth writing about
we are like roses that have never
bothered to bloom when we should have
bloomed and it is as if the sun has
become disgusting with waiting
you have to die a few times before you
can really live
nobody can save you but yourself
and you're worth saving
it's a war not easily won
but if anything is worth winning then
this is it
life's as kind as you let it be
the free soul is rare
but you know it when you see it
basically because you feel good very
good
when you are near or with them
sex is a great thing only
when there is nothing else to do
if you managed to deceive a person
this does not mean that he is a fool
it means that you were trusted more than
you deserve it
beauty is nothing
beauty won't stay
you don't know how lucky you are to be
ugly
because if people like you
you know it's for something else
too often the people complain that they
have done nothing with their lives
and then they wait for somebody to tell
them
that this isn't so
great art is horseshit
by tacos
[Music]
i often carry things to read so that i
will not have to look at the people
the woman who smiles at you when you
meet her is most likely just planning to
feed her ego
for those who believe in god
most of the big questions are answered
but for those of us who can't readily
accept the god formula
the big answers don't remain stone
written
some people like what you do
some people hate what you do
but most people simply don't give a damn
never say three things about yourself
your plans your income
and the number of people you've slept
with
as long as the man has wine and
cigarettes
he can endure a lot
and why do women always need the
husbands of other women
and why do horse thieves always prefer a
tamed horse to a wild one
[Music]
love is a form of prejudice
you love what you need
you love what makes you feel good
you love what is convenient
drinking is an emotional thing
it joggles you out of the standardism of
everyday life
out of everything being the same
you